sometimes dolphins leap out of the water
for plain fun
other times they're twisting and turning
to shake off pesky hitchhikers known as
remoras
remoras save energy by sticking to all
sorts of surfaces from the hard shell of
turtles to the rough skin of sharks
while remore is burst out of the water
by attaching to other swimmers
some animals such as the kingfisher can
propel themselves into water and out of
it snagging prey along the way
inspired by the strong grip of
suckerfish and the swift swoop of
kingfishers researchers set out to
create the ultimate swimming flying and
retrieving robot
drones and survey bots can't lug giant
batteries on board they need to conserve
power whenever possible
the researchers set out to replicate the
remora's energy saving strategy by
recreating its sticky disk
remoras use lamellae slat like bones
encased in soft tissues and spinules
rows of hard teeth like tissue to latch
on
in 2017 the researchers created a
layered disk inspired by these features
but two big improvements were needed
getting rid of the tether and making the
disks suction not just with the outer
lip but also adding suction to
individual lamella
to get rid of the tether the researchers
installed two very small water pumps on
the robot
one pump bends the disc to position it
along a surface while the other controls
the lamellae
once the disk presses down on a surface
a tight seal is created from the
difference in pressure between the
compartment and environment as well as
the slight rotation of the lamellae to
make the robot latch even stronger fluid
is pumped from the chamber back to the
lamellae this further rotates the
lamellae and engages the spinules it
also reduces the pressure in the
compartment improving adhesion even more
by creating multiple seals the disc can
stick around even if some of the
compartments aren't firmly attached just
as the researchers observed in real life
remoras
the disc could latch on to a variety of
surfaces both in the air and underwater
from the curved smooth shell of a
mollusk to surfaces riddled with
microorganisms
the disc can stay attached to surfaces
for hours and even hitch a ride onto
moving objects
next the researchers channeled the
capabilities of a kingfisher
and added flight to their hitch-hiking
robot
the robot uses propellers to swim to the
surface then shoot itself out of the
water in less than half a second
outside the lab the robot proved it
could deal with different environments
throughout these excursions a camera on
board provided a view of the surrounding
environment while the robot can only
swim up to a depth of about 2 meters
before wireless communication cuts out
it can continue to record at greater
depths
in the future the researchers hope to
add other monitors on board such as a
sensor to detect when the disk is fully
attached or if there's a leak
someday this little bot might be diving
for your phone when you drop it off the
boardwalk or riding along on a whale's
journey
[Music]
[Music]